it just makes me slur my words well i
moved in
to my new house i
am struggling
the current project's occurring i told
me workflows i'm trying to think
okay so we recently got these new
headphones and it really reminded me of
this app that i used to play with my
friends called speech zapper it hacks
your brain and makes you unable to talk
properly
that was just me
excuse me i haven't even started it and
i can't talk
so how does it work it's actually a
super super simple yet ingenious way
that this app is able to hack your brain
what it does is it actually plays back a
live feed of what it's recording through
the microphone directly to your ears so
you're hearing your own voice as you're
talking but here's the caveat it's
actually delaying that sound feed by
just you know a little bit psychologists
have found that it's impossible to speak
when you hear your words played back to
you with a slight delay okay so now it's
working
it's kind of getting me
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to decrease the
the did i say declise
decrease the delay
it's working now i've got the speech
jammer going i've got a slight delay in
how i'm actually listening for myself
why are you talking so weird this is the
speech jammer okay so i've got some
shrunken oysters here uh willy's really
wary all right uh i'm gonna i got
something
i'm sorry six sticky skeletons i'm very
confused you know what you do it you do
it okay so what i just talk now yeah how
now brown cow
what's up derek a big black bear set on
a big black rug get down
i'm too smart
as i write this snow softly falls from
my throat it's closed it's about to
throw me off once in a while the back of
her knee and traces the calf her map
with an index finger okay yeah this
isn't working for me it's the settings
isn't it
i'm excited to try this
this is the most like disaster of a 3d
print i've ever encountered you have to
sort of look at it like this a merk in
his fake pubic hair
in normal television shows the title of
the episode does not matter at all like
you've never even seen it you ignore it
completely you're just like oh you want
to watch breaking bad sure
our titles matter to get people to watch
videos so obviously only like this many
people even have youtube red even with i
guess a lot more right now because it's
free right now for like three months
which is cool don't don't sign up just
yet wait until we release lifeline so
you can at least watch that so anyways
moving back on lifeline is on youtube
it's actually on the quarter channel so
here's the thing the title and the
thumbnail still need to be
just as banging as any other youtube
video ma'am gets into time travel
accident whoa youtube red i know welcome
to the future of the television the
episode one title is good it's in 33
days you're going to die
that's a pretty good title see they they
nailed that episodes five six seven and
eight like honestly i don't care what
their titles are gonna be but the first
four i'd say are incredibly important to
be
like very clicky very enticing it's just
so weird to have a narrative show named
like a youtube video i know isn't that
so weird so i'm trying to figure out
right now like what do we do also how
great are those piglet headphones huh i
know they're pretty awesome
the sennheiser pxc 550s great do they
turn off when you pack them up like
click and now it's off and then
and now it's on
yeah yeah there's a touchpad so
right here you can turn the volume up
and down skip songs fast forward and
double tap it and then the microphones
on it turn on so it amplifies the
outdoor audio so you can talk to people
so you can have your noise removal
turned on so it's all like you know
keeping things quiet you're just
chilling out and like somebody starts to
talk to you go boop
and then you can talk to everybody and
you can hear them and you go boop and
you re-enter your world it's really cool
and it has noise removal on while it
amplifies stuff so it's like gives you
extra like crisp human hearing and i was
playing battlegrounds using these and
there's a speech enhanced mode which
will also do volume leveling so if it's
quiet it starts raising all the volume
so like when i'm sitting in a building
like stalking somebody
like all the ambient audio starts to
come up until you get a gunfight then
all suppresses again it's really cool
i win a lot of games with these babies
so now i increase the delay a little bit
more shouldn't do jet
it's this is literally just a slider bar
sliding it wasn't working on nick and
myself by mid morning tuesday i i
keep reading mid-morning tuesday i'd
settled into my desk the following the
events of daybreak and not too happy
with my great aunt reading the front
page headlines as she intermittently
blew steam off her coffee where where
are you picking up from i don't know man
it's no hype that my agency has shown
more doctors into this town than all the
others combined no i hear my voice i'm
just like yeah i'm cutting through it
just tune it out can you like turn the
delay down making it
closer to what i'm actually saying oh
he's struggling
we just end up talking like william
shatner no i have to like wait for the
delay
to be able to talk
good
super bowl the longer it's terrible
already on the phone with somebody that
has
delay
just trying to talk
normally
i am struggling
tell us about your house so i moved in
to my new house
two
weeks ago
but yeah it's
right there
puget systems
is based on a simple philosophy offer
outstanding support
and your product will sell itself
an
internet page where your marketing is
more important than your product
it just makes me slur my words
how did you how did you feel
i've been working here since sink what
am i slurring wear this for a whole day
hello hello who's coming by and what for
adobe's project manager is coming by and
whoa okay okay
the project managers for adobe come by
and they want to see what the workflow
is between our projects two people from
adobe are coming through and they want
to
talk to us about
the current projects that currently
workflows i'm trying to think
disaster of a 3d print i've ever
encountered
it looks like it's well you know if
you're 3d printing package material it's
totally successful i kind of think this
is rather amazing this is supposed to be
a battery case well it actually is it's
just the molecules have been arranged
differently than you're drawing
it it is a 3d battery case this will
protect the battery if you wrap it in
and just take some duct tape it will
just look different the difference is oh
there's a poop
there's just more molecules between the
case than there would be this is
this is an opportunity look what it's
doing it's printing a hard case look
it's just printing air now you've
achieved something here wren does that
have artificial intelligence it does now
well what this could be also is there's
a thing have you ever heard of of when
either a man or a woman is lacking pubic
hair they get what's called a merkin a
merkin is fake pubic hair you have to
sort of look at it like this it's a
merkin this is fake see in fact there's
so much of it here that it is enough to
share and it could be peeking out from
underneath your shorts here and there
people would find it quite unusual
seriously it's pretty cool actually
you and you programmed this i think
you're you're
look look at this man these other pieces
that we printed too check this out wow
this was 3d printed niko modeled this
himself and printed it pretty cool this
is how how big the base was supposed to
be and it was supposed to go up it's a
box it's literally i think it was
overcome yeah i think what happened is
right after it got to the base there's a
design flaw in that because
it went
that's look at that it's pretty good
until it gets above that level
yeah it's the first time i've seen
anything like this this is great i live
to come over here to solve problems and
see
new innovations like this it's like
where do you find the line between you
know click bait and
something worthy of a tv show exactly so
at first upset title though what was it
you have 33 days
in in 33 days you're going to die
that's an intense title they sent me the
list and i just called them and said hey
these titles would work right if this
was like on a network tv thing but this
is youtube so
they have to be good titles that make
you want to click on it i gotta figure
out the rest of these titles or at least
proposals for one to four see here's the
thing i don't know that much about the
series i haven't seen any of the
episodes i haven't seen any rough cuts
i've seen a few vfx shots that was those
were pretty cool
oh yeah there's a trailer
dude i want to watch this trip i'm
excited that's what i've been waiting
for i was literally just talking about
that over the weekend who plays lifeline
how did you know my name
who are you
i work for a company called lifeline he
made a wise choice coming to life
changing the future can save lives
changing the past destroys them
my reaction is positively positive
no i'm excited when do you think the
trailer will go up
is it going on our channel
wait really yeah what are you doing what
are you talking about what oh yeah
you're right it's gonna come on early
next week what up
i totally forgot about that anyways
we're gonna put the trailer for life
early next week
but what about all the effects that
aren't even done
i actually did one of those shots oh
nice it's the one that's the one where
she falls off the road so yeah when you
guys are watching this the trailer drop
early next week on the corridor channel
subscribe to both channels to check it
out
dude this is news to me man
don't you think i should know these
types of things
it just melts plastic yeah so it feeds
it through this tube and then it melts
in this little hot end here and then it
just makes a design it's incredible and
it made that this is a
dice roller
wait a second made this
with those steps interior steps going in
a little gate that goes down oh
my
sam painted it afterwards
what it can't 3d paint did he make
somebody to put behind the dungeon in
there is that teddy oh
a guy holding the bars and like
lamenting not being able to ever get out
details yes like a vision of sam sam
himself 3d print that is sam yeah
it's 3d printed out of sandstone i don't
[ __ ] colored sandstone oh my god that
is nico
god that's spooky scary oh
my
god
wow could you imagine oh whoa whoa whoa
3d print all of you guys all of you guys
that size
chess board
all of you guys
chess games would be the queen who'd be
the king obviously peter would be the
pawn oh you'd have guys with with the
knights that stand in there with that
with a sword you'd have the the castles
on the end the castle guys
have have a corduroy digital that's
actually a really good idea do you guys
want to see us do that we'd have to
start by 3d scanning all of us here in
the office which is something we've
already talked about starting to do
you've got you oh
no who would be the bishops i think i
would be the bishop the bishop because
the bishop like ow
right
you know
the one who slides up and down the chess
board
like i don't know like on one wheel you
know what's so great about that so ran
out of one a one-wheels a bishop what's
so great about that is he's young and
he'll recover from that
god that really hurt oh my god yeah yeah
i saw that
that's like like getting something
caught in your zipper when you're out of
the sporting event well it's okay if you
have this
oh the american yeah the merc and you're
you're fine yeah the market hey
everybody in the studio can i have your
attention for a second here uh we have a
drive with errors on the corridor raid
it's showing that the the drive is at
risk
to find out what happens make sure
you're subscribed and your notifications
turned on
[Music]
you